you know there are essential tools for
birding there your binoculars your
spotting scope your field guide and if
you're black you're going to need
probably two or three forms of ID never
wear a hoodie
the word for an african-american and
camouflage is incog-negro black birds
are your birds red-winged blackbirds
grackles rusty blackbirds Brewers black
birds blacks coders acclaimed black
Brant crows Ravens and black birds are
larger than the line any bird that's
black is my bird
you know the edge of day is light is
fading those corpuscular hours are the
times when many birds come to life it's
such a beautiful time to bird but if
you're black Berger and you're gonna
bird at night you better be careful
because you might be perceived as being
up to no good
be prepared to be confused with the
other blackbirder
when I meet another blackbirder it's
like encountering an ivory-billed
woodpecker an endangered species
extinction looms these are the rules for
the black birder
we have to do something to make birdie
to make nature steady in general more
interesting to people of color out of
every hundred bird watchers how many are
black yeah